mes chers collègues
nous avons été informés le 7 avril
dernier
que le Président de la République
envisagé de vous nommer aux fonctions de
président de la Commission nationale du
débat public CNDP comme vous savez cette
nomination ne peut intervenir qu'après
l'audition de la personne pressenti
devant les commissions compétentes de
l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat audition
qui doivent être suivis d'un vote cette
audition est publique cette audition est
ouverte à la presse à son issue nous
procéderons au vote pour lequel il ne
peut y avoir de délégation de vote la
commission du développement durable et
de l'Aménagement du Territoire de
l'Assemblée nationale vous entendrez
également à son tour le 10 mai à 15h et
c'est à l'issue de cette deuxième
audition que nous procéderons au
dépouillement simultané de ce scrutin
avec celui de l'Assemblée nationale
je suis heureux que cette édition ait
lieu
je ne serai pas plus long je vais
laisser la parole à Bruno rejoint
désigné rapporteur le soin de vous
interroger sur les enjeux en jeu
relatifs à votre indépendance je vous
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
13 de la Constitution il ne pourra être
procédé à cette nomination si l'addition
des votes négatifs de chaque commission
représentait au moins 3/5 des suffrages
exprimés dans les deux dans les deux
commissions je vais laisser la porte la
parole en d'autres rapporteur Bruno
rejoint qui va conduire votre audition
vous pourrez ensuite nous présenter
votre candidature et nous faire part de
vos motivations avant de répondre aux
premières questions du rapporteur à
l'issue de ce premier échange mes
collègues vous interrogeront à leur tour
pour une séquence de questions réponses
je vous remercie la parole est en
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues monsieur papynuty
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
examiner votre candidature à la
présidence de la Commission nationale du
débat public afin de nous permettre d'en
apprécier l'opportunité nous allons tous
ensemble
appréhender ce matin les forces mais
aussi les faiblesses de votre
candidature à la tête de cet institution
le rôle exact l'utilité et l'impact réel
de son action son fréquemment remis en
question c'est pourquoi à titre
liminaire il m'a paraît nécessaire de
les évoquer pour mieux apprécier les
enjeux que soulève votre candidature
la CNDP a été créée en 1995 par la loi
Barnier relative au renforcement de la
protection de l'environnement
depuis 2002 c'est une autorité
administrative indépendante elle est
chargée de veiller au respect de la
participation du public au processus
d'élaboration des projets d'aménagement
ou d'équipement dès lors qu'il présente
de forts enjeux socio-économiques ou ont
des impacts significatifs sur
l'environnement ou l'aménagement du
territoire
cette participation du public peut
prendre la forme d'un débat public
qu'organise la CNDP pour les projets
plus importants ce débat est obligatoire
par son action elle doit donc diffuser
une culture de la concertation et
favoriser l'adhésion de la population au
projet grâce à la prise en compte ou au
moins à l'écoute de tous les points de
vue
toutefois l'efficacité de l'action de la
CNDP suscite des interrogations
légitimes
cette institution souffre tout d'abord
d'un fort manque de notoriété qui pose
la question de savoir si elle a
réellement la capacité de mener à bien
ses missions par ailleurs elle n'a pas
été capable d'organiser le grand débat
national voulu par le Président de la
République en 2019 les dissensions entre
le gouvernement et sa présidente couplée
à la polémique sur sa rémunération
perçue comme excessive par l'opinion
l'ont empêché de jouer un rôle dans une
concertation qui était pourtant au cœur
de son cœur de son champ d'action
plus largement la CNDP ne semble pas
aujourd'hui avoir la capacité
d'organiser des débats apaisés sur les
projets sur lesquels elle est saisie
son action n'a pas su pour l'instant
prévenir la naissance ou apaiser les
fortes tensions autour des grands
projets d'aménagement ce constat a mené
un député à déposer en janvier 2023 lors
de l'examen du projet de loi
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires un amendement de suppression
de la CNDP selon lui l'apparition de
zone à défendre à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
et à Bures mais aussi l'absence de prise
en compte réel des oppositions locales
au grand projet sont le signe de son peu
d'utilité
les décisions seraient déjà prises avant
la concertation l'expérience de
démocratie participative locale serait
factice et donc condamné à échouer face
à ces critiques quel est Monsieur
papinetti pour vous la place que doit
avoir la CNDP dans le processus de
décision
cette question on appelle immédiatement
une seconde celle de l'articulation
entre l'expérience de démocratie
participative que représente la CNDP et
la démocratie représentative le projet
de loi construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires a montré les
tensions qui peuvent apparaître entre
les deux la CNDP menée en effet depuis
plusieurs mois un débat sur le nucléaire
demain
et n'avait pas encore rendu ses
conclusions quand à l'initiative du
Sénat la loi a supprimé les critères de
limitation de la production nucléaire
dans son compte-rendu de débat la CNDP a
déploré une rupture de confiance et une
perte de son utilité même du fait de ce
calendrier imprévu
quel est selon vous la mars à suivre
pour s'assurer d'une meilleure
articulation entre les travaux du
Parlement et ceux de la CNDP
j'en viens à présent à aborder la
question de la pertinence de votre
profil en particulier pour occuper ce
poste
vous avez travaillé dans des secteurs
qui vous ont conféré une expertise
indéniable sur les grands projets
concernés par le débat public
vous avez notamment été directeur
général de voies navigable de France
jusqu'en 2017 année vous êtes devenus
directeur de cabinet d'Elizabeth borne
alors ministre des Transports jusqu'en
2019 vous avez ensuite été directeur
général des infrastructures des
transports et des mobilités avant de
finalement revenir à la tête d'un
cabinet ministériel entre juillet 2022
et février dernier en tant que directeur
de cabinet de Christophe Béchu ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
je n'ai donc aucun doute comme sans
doute l'ensemble de mes collègues ici
présents sur vos compétences et vos
connaissances toutefois alors que vous
avez travaillé étroitement avec Madame
borne et Monsieur Béchu ces dernières
années je ne peux m'empêcher de
m'interroger sur votre capacité à faire
preuve de l'indépendance nécessaire et
même indispensable à la fonction de
président d'une autorité administrative
indépendante deux surcroît la CNDP
définit dans sa charte de déontologie
que sa première valeur est justement
l'indépendance
la simple apparence d'un tel manque
qu'elle soit fondée ou non et de nature
à décrédibiliser l'impartialité de la
scène d'épée dans la tenue des débats la
fonction même de président de la CNDP et
toutes les exigences qu'elle emporte en
termes d'impartialité pour mener à bien
ses missions vous semble-t-elle de
nature à vous permettre de vous départir
de tout éventuel pression du
gouvernement
votre prédécesseur madame Jouanneau a
d'ailleurs Suin incarner cette valeur de
façon très forte dans la continuité de
votre décesseur si demain vous étiez
nommé président de la CNDP pensez-vous
monsieur papinuti pouvoir de la même
façon être en capacité de prendre
position en toute liberté vis-à-vis des
ministres que vous avez servi avec le
plus la plus grande loyauté ces
dernières années
j'en viens à présent à la cruciale
question du déport qui me semble vous
concerner en premier chef
ces dernières années que ce soit en tant
que directeur général des
infrastructures des transports et des
mobilités ou en tant que directeur de
cabinet vous avez eu à connaître de très
nombreux dossiers concernant notamment
les infrastructures de transport par
conséquent si votre nomination est
confirmée les déports sur ces dossiers
devraient avoir lieu
avez-vous une idée de leur ampleur
n'est-ce pas une vraie difficulté alors
que le poste auquel vous candidatez
exige deux si consacrer entièrement
par ailleurs vous deviez il y a quelques
semaines vous présenter devant notre
commission pour qu'elle se prononce sur
votre candidature non pas à la
présidence de la CNDP mais à celle du
conseil d'administration de l'Autorité
de régulation des transports
des questions analogues quant à votre
indépendance et à l'ampleur des déports
nécessaires se poser alors cette seconde
candidature peut donner l'impression
d'une tentative de nomination pour
service rendu indépendamment bien sûr de
votre compétence et même de votre goût
et de votre motivation que je ne mets
pas en doute que répondez-vous à ces
critiques
en conclusion monsieur papinutti je suis
convaincu de vos compétences et de votre
parfaite connaissance des enjeux dans
lesquels s'insère l'action de la CNDP
vous l'aurez compris ce qui est
indispensable pour nous parlementaire
c'est de s'assurer de votre capacité à
acquérir l'indépendance nécessaire à la
fonction et de veiller à ce que les
règles de déport qui s'appliqueraient à
votre cas n'aurait pas d'incidence sur
le bon fonctionnement de la CNDP je vous
invite donc à nous éclairer et nous
allons écouter les éléments que vous
voudrez bien apporter à l'ensemble des
questionnements soulevés
monsieur le Président si vous n'y voyez
pas d'inconvénient je tiens d'abord à
vous remercier vous à remercier mes
collègues de la de la commission pour
leur confiance remercier Stéphanie Samy
et l'ensemble des personnes qui m'ont
aidé et notamment les deux jeunes
administrateurs Lucas de Silva et
Grégoire billet pour leur travail et
leur écoute merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour le
travail réalisé je vais donner la parole
à Monsieur Marc papinutti vous avez la
parole
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames laissées
natrices messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord je suis très heureux de me
présenter devant vous dans le cadre du
processus de nomination merci pour cette
audition qui me permet de présenter ma
candidature à la présidence de la
Commission nationale du débat public la
CNDP je suis ici parce que je suis
convaincu que les transitions en cours
écologiques sociales énergétique sont
déterminants pour notre société dans son
ensemble que chacun de nos citoyens y
sont confrontés ainsi que le milieu
naturel bien évidemment ma conviction
profonde vous l'avez cité monsieur le
rapporteur conforté par 40 années
d'engagements total et résolu au service
d'un intérêt général c'est que ces
transitions ne pourront se faire que
avec l'adhésion de nos concitoyens leur
participation aux décisions est un
préalable indispensable nous semble-t-il
avant de vous présenter mon parcours les
orientations que j'entends vous proposer
pour la CNDP dans les témoins de revenir
sur les circonstances de ma double
proposition de nomination évoquée par
vous monsieur le rapporteur le président
de la République avait vous le savez
proposé ma domination à la prison de
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
cette nomination si elle avait
évidemment accueilli Laval de votre
commission m'aurait obligé de me
déporter sur un nombre trop important de
dossiers en effet après analyse plus
poussée il est apparu que mon parcours
entraînait d'importantes situations
d'incompatibilité avec les fonctions
pour laquelle j'avais proposé j'étais
proposé pendant une partie du mandat
aussi je le dis tout de suite en
conscience j'ai préféré me retirer à
titre personnel
je suis extrêmement honoré aujourd'hui
d'être moi ancien diplômé de l'école
d'ingénieur des travaux publics de
l'État après 40 années au service de
l'intérêt général proposé à votre choix
autour de ma carrière je me suis
absolument toujours attaché à écouter
tous les publics avec la même attention
que participer ainsi que participer à
vos auditions parlementaires
personnellement ça a été le cas si je
peux le rappeler dans une histoire assez
ancienne déjà à la fin des années 90
avec le Plan de Déplacement Urbain
d'Île-de-France ou pour le grand projet
du canal senor à partir de 2003 avait NF
le débat public commun sur la plaine de
La Bassée l'aménagement de la liaison
fluviale braine-nogent a été aussi
l'occasion d'un débat au combien
d'actualité sur les usages de l'eau au
sein des cabinets ministériels lors du
Grenelle de l'environnement ou des
Assises de la mobilité qui ont donné
lieu à la l'homme qui sont deux grands
moments de concertation et de
construction collective qui à mon avis
font date et puis plus généralement on
ces dernières années dans le cadre de
non-roger infrastructures ferroviaire
aux routières pour le fret qu'il soit
d'ailleurs routier ferroviaire ou
fluvial y compris pendant la période
covid
je peux citer plus récemment pour la
construction dans le bas d'ambition
nationale pour le vélo à l'aide du
déploiement de solutions aussi de
transport avec France mobilité ou grâce
aux associations au territoire nous
avons construit des solutions
toutes ces expériences m'ont permis de
voir de monter ce besoin complémentaire
de démocratie participative sous toutes
ses formes en complément j'y reviendrai
de la traditionnelle démocratie
représentative aussi en complément de la
légitimité technique comme en tant
qu'ingénieur je peux d'ailleurs ajouter
que la meilleure des solutions
techniques vous le savez comme moi
n'appe poids si elle n'est pas partagée
il me faudra donc si vous acceptez cette
candidature garantir cette participation
à la construction des politiques
publiques particulièrement celles qui
ont un impact sur l'environnement pour
la CNP je serai particulièrement attaché
à son indépendance sur ma propre
indépendance et ceux qui me connaissent
Sabla ayant avec laquelle j'ai exercé
des fonctions au service de l'intérêt
général j'avoue qu'à mon âge je ne dois
pas bien ou qui ou quoi pourrait
maintenant encore menacer mon
appartialité en complément je vous
rappelle que la CNDP est composé d'un
bureau permanent président
22 commissaires personnalités qualifiées
magistrate et magistrat personnalité élu
repente d'associations des syndicats ils
sont désignés eux-mêmes par 19
organismes et seront donc garantir cette
indépendance ainsi que la Haute Autorité
de la vie publique si nécessaire
ma proposition de candidature s'inscrit
donc dans la continuité de ses
présidents successifs récents je peux
vous lisser leur rendre hommage Philippe
Deslandes Christian lérides et tout
particulièrement Chantal joano que vous
connaissez bien
pour mémoire vous l'avez dit la
commission nationale a été créée par la
loi bornier elle est garante du droit à
l'information et la participation du
public à l'élaboration des plantes
programmes et projet ayant incidence sur
l'environnement la CNDP a une obligation
de neutralité absolue elle se prononce
donc pas sur l'opportunité du projet ni
sur le bien-fondé des arguments
ces missions sont exercées par 340 et
garants nommés indemnisés par mission la
CNDP l'institution qui est la plus forte
expérience européenne de la
participation avec 106 débats publics
427 concertations et procédures
participations
elle a traité d'ailleurs ces cinq
dernières années par des changements de
seuil plus de saisine que les 20 années
précédentes
sa place est croissante
son rôle également puisque les deux
tiers des projets sont modifiés après ce
processus participatif
l'ouvrira pas le débat des effectifs
sachez simplement que cette croissance a
été assumée par deux ETP soit au total
15 ETP en incluant le bureau son budget
d'environ 4 millions de dépenses dont la
moitié est assurée par des fonds de
concours des maîtres d'ouvrage et son
frais fonctionnement sont d'un million
d'euros alors je souhaite maintenant
décrire mes actions les actions que
j'envisage si vous prononcez
favorablement sur ma candidature bien
évidemment la première action à court
terme sera de mieux présenté le travail
de essentiel de la SNDP le travail
réalisé et ainsi que sa contribution
future pour la démocratie représentative
la CNDP bénéficie d'une expérience
unique 25 ans sans équivalent en Europe
elle a expérimenté toutes les méthodes
participatives elle a eu à connaître
vous l'avez cité des cimes déjà
éminemment conflictuels cette
reconnaissance elle est confirmée par la
très forte augmentation des missions de
conseils ou d'expertise c'est-à-dire
hors du champ obligatoire
dans la même lignée ça sera mieux faire
connaître les saisines possibles dans le
cadre législatif et réglementaire actuel
s'agira aussi de renforcer le lien et
vous l'avez citer que la remontation
nationale est dans les territoires par
l'installation des délégués de région
j'ai également pris connaissance de
plusieurs rapports publics ces documents
dans une première action dans une
deuxième action devront être analysé
collectivement pour déterminer les
suites à donner ça pourrait être à la
fois des transformations réglementaires
des transformations législatives y
inclure aussi les expériences étrangères
en Italie au Québec de même nature c'est
aussi là que devront être choisis les
orientations stratégiques entre devenir
l'instant de la démocratie purement
environnementale ou être celle de
l'instance participative
en parallèle en troisième action mais
vous l'imaginer il faut poursuivre la
professionnalisation du vivier des
garants assurer son renouvellement et sa
mixité
dans une quatrième action il s'avère me
semble-t-il indispensable de confirmer
le rôle d'une autorité garante du droit
à l'information et à la participation et
puis probablement diversifier encore les
moyens pour s'assurer que l'on touche
les publics les plus larges et pour cela
il faut élargir les partenariats et les
méthodes afin de viser l'inclusion des
publics éloignés dans les dispositifs
participatifs actuels et ne pas craindre
des nouvelles expérimentations et de
trouver des modes pour vérifier les
faits ce qu'on appelle le fac checking
plutôt dynamique lorsque nous sommes en
phase de débat enfin il me semblerait
indispensable de mieux utiliser les
compétences existantes à la scène d'épée
sur des sujets nouveaux car les méthodes
de la participation citoyenne peuvent
être s'appliquer à de nombreux sujets
agricultures santé haut notamment il
s'agirait aussi d'aider les maîtres
d'ouvrage et leur bureau d'études
d'avoir une culture on va dire plus
sociotechnique pour que l'accès à tous
les documents soient possibles
et que la participation continue
s'exerce complètement
plus concrètement dans la ligne de ce
qui est en cours vous l'avez cité moi je
de débats qui se sont réalisés je pense
qu'il serait important que le Parlement
est donc votre commission vos
commissions compétentes puissent
entendre les garants de la concertation
sur le mix énergétique et la Commission
particulière du débat panli dans les
commissions compétentes afin de préparer
la lpec
je pense aussi que nous préparons les
débats sur les documents stratégiques de
façade sur la planification des trois
façades il y a des débats qui sont venus
aussi sont là préparés la débat sur la
mine de lithium
je suis convaincu aux enjeux actuels de
l'eau qui a un débat entre une
méthodologie sur l'eau qui peut
compléter ce qui a déjà été préparé par
la commission
parce qu'en fait on y retrouve des
dangers de santé publique de
biodiversité d'agriculture d'énergie de
transport le tourisme et de multiples
acteurs qui sont impliqués dans tous les
numéros de gouvernance des déchets
territoriales qui ne sont pas en plus
l'organisation territoriale de l'État
habituel
travail qui a déjà enté entamé je pense
aussi à une saisie éventuelle sur la
biodiversité qui n'est pas dans le champ
des plans et programmes et un travail
sur le projet de loi industrie verte sur
lequel je ne doute pas que vous aurez
des questions mais sur lequel je n'ai
pas encore les éléments à ce jour je ne
voudrais pas être plus long et si à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions je me suis toujours engagé
résolument dans l'exercice des fonctions
qui étaient les miennes et l'exerçant
pleinement l'expérience conforte chaque
jour à la liberté la capacité
d'initiative qui sont les miennes dans
le cadre fixé par les lois et règlements
je pense que plusieurs membres de votre
commission l'ont déjà remarqué je vous
remercie de votre attention
et suis bien sûr prêt à vous répondre à
vos à vous répondre faut-il que je
réponde tout de suite à monsieur le
rapporteur sur des points ou
je vais donner la parole à Joël Bigot
et après je répondrai
deux autres puis vous répondrez
globalement aux trois plus ce rapporteur
merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues monsieur
le candidat
ça a déjà été dit mais ne vous
attendions précédemment pour l'Autorité
de régulation des transports mais le
sort on a décidé autrement in extremiste
on vous éditionne aujourd'hui donc pour
la candidature soumise par le Président
de la République aux fonctions de
président de la Commission nationale du
débat public cette commission comme a
été dit par Monsieur rejoint tout à
l'heure a été créé en 1995 pour
renforcer la protection de
l'environnement en 2002 elle est devenue
une autorité administrative indépendante
et les ordonnances de 2016 en
considérablement élargi ses compétences
la CNDP participe à la garantie du droit
au débat conformément à l'article 7 de
la Charte de l'environnement de 2004
depuis 2018 Chantal Jouanno l'actuel
présidente a donné à voir son
impartialité par sa punicité à l'égard
du pouvoir exécutif et au texte
gouvernementaux qui nous ont été
présentés
nous connaissons votre parcours au sein
de nombreux cabinets ministériels que
vous avez dirigés vous avez été la
cheville ouvrière de nombreux projets de
loi relatifs à l'aménagement du
territoire et à l'environnement qui ont
accéléré les procédures de consultation
du public tout en invoquant le principe
d'intérêt public majeur
membre du Conseil national de la
transition écologique j'ai pu avoir
accès aux nouveaux projets de loi pour
l'industrie verte que le gouvernement
porte désormais et qui comporte une
réforme importante de la consultation du
public en son article 2 et maintenant un
nouvel article 2 bis
la compagnie nationale des commissaires
enquêteurs vient de nous transmettre un
avis sur cet article la CNSE s'inquiète
je cite de l'absence de définition à ce
stade des projets concernés et alerte
sur une possible généralisation
s'appliquant à tous les projets la CNCE
démontre que l'article 2 du projet de
loi relatif à la participation du public
ne s'inscrit pas dans le titre 2 du
livre premier du code de l'environnement
relatif à l'information et à la
participation des citoyens et donc n'en
respecte ni l'esprit ni les principes le
déballement le débat parlementaire qui
s'ouvrira nous permettra à coup sûr d'en
discuter mais face à cette instabilité
juridique en matière de débat public je
crois que nous avons plus que jamais
besoin d'une Commission nationale du
débat public indépendant et d'une
neutralité à toute épreuve au regard de
votre parcours dévoué au gouvernement de
cette législature je m'interroge sur
votre capacité à GA des avis impartiaux
quand au projet de loi qui nous arrive
même si vous avez invoqué l'âge de
sagesse laquelle vous êtes arrivés sans
consultation et participation réelles du
public la volonté d'accélérer les
projets ne peut être menée à bien aussi
Monsieur le candidat je vous demanderai
que comment comptez-vous garantir cette
indépendance et cette neutralité de la
CNDP sous votre éventuel je dis bien
éventuelle présidence je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Frédéric marchand merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais
revenir sur un point à la fois abordé
par notre rapporteur et par vous même
monsieur papinotti vous interrogez sur
la façon dont vous envisagez si vous
êtes élu les relations entre la CNDP et
la représentation nationale les plus
encore notre assemblée j'en ai fait
l'impression mais peut-être n'est-ce
qu'une impression que ce n'est pas la
fluidité qui l'emporte toujours à ce
jour alors même que nous aurions
collectivement atterré à développer des
échanges sur des sujets sous lesquels
nous avons à connaître les uns et les
autres vous avez d'ailleurs dans votre
présentation évoquée le sujet de
l'énergie et tout le travail mené par la
CNDP avec le débat sur le mix
énergétique j'avais pu participer à une
réunion dans le département du Nord et
voir quelle était la pétance du public
et des élus nombreux présents ou bien
encore la consultation passée sur la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et la nécessité bien
évidemment au-delà de ces consultations
de développer des passerelles aussi au
regard des sujets qui sont devant nous
nous aurions bien évidemment tout
intérêt à développer nos interactions et
même si vous avez déjà bordé le sujet
j'aimerais donc savoir plus précisément
quelle piste serait les vôtres pour
tendre vers cette plus grande fluidité
que vous appelez de nos vœux et que je
pense nous aussi à plan de nos vœux
merci
mes chers collègues à Martine filleul
qui
lors de la cérémonie de départ de
l'ex-présidente de la CNDP Chantal
Jouanno avait mis en garde celui ou
celle qui doit lui succéder je cite si
on continue d'une main à écrire
participation dans tous les discours et
de l'autre des tricoter le droit de
participation on prend les gens pour des
idiots et ils s'en rendent compte le
Citizen washing c'est
anti-démocratique personnellement je
souscris à cette lecture
en effet alors même que sur la demande
alors même que la demande de
participation directe de nos concitoyens
à l'action publique n'a jamais été aussi
forte les projets de loi accélération
des énergies renouvelables en novembre
dernier a vu sur réduire le rôle clé de
la démocratie environnementale des
commissaires enquêteurs et avec
industrie verte il est proposé de
réduire les délais de passage en sienne
d'épée pour les projets jusqu'à même
proposer une alternative en les
exonérant de ce passage dès lors qu'il
contribue à la décarbonation je
souhaitais monsieur papinotti obtenir
votre lecture personnelle de cette
déclaration de Madame Jouanneau
approuvez-vous cette décision de réduire
le pouvoir de la commission à laquelle
vous postulez par l'exécutif dont vous
êtes
issu ensuite et cela peut paraître
anecdotique mais souhaitez vous
interroger sur
l'électronisme et les méthodes de
consultation de nos concitoyens
je m'interroge sur l'exclusion leur
exclusion lors du recours à exclusif à
des enquêtes publiques en ligne quand on
quand on dit vous faire pour justement
remédier à ce problème et faire que
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens puissent
être consultés effectivement je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur
papinutier je vous propose de répondre à
Joël Bigot Frédéric marchand et à Martin
filleul et on rapporte
merci Président
je vais revenir sur un premier point sur
le manque de notoriété qui a dit le
rapporteur c'est un sujet que alors il
faut que je parle plus fort dans le
micro plus près peut-être
je
connais les CMDP par soi même monde
depuis des années donc je suis habitué à
travailler avec elle mais je dirais que
c'est la partie repentation technique et
sociotechnique
j'ai compris et je vous renvoie la balle
de la même manière
l'autorité régression des transports
vous les auditionnez vous auditionnez le
président régulièrement je pense que le
travail de fond que nous avons à faire
et j'en ai parlé avec les deux
vice-présidents en Corée hier ça serait
de trouver les moments où on peut
échanger avec vous moi je vous
proposerai ce premier point c'était de
voir les garants de du débat sur la de
la concertation sur le mix énergétique
et le président de la commission
particulière du débat public sur Pandi
les réacteurs nucléaires je crois que
c'est ces moments-là qu'il faut refaire
au niveau national qui ne se font pas
c'est pas simplement le rapport de
d'activités qui suffit après je suis
très optimiste parce que je pense que le
la démocratie au niveau territorial et
locale est un vrai besoin et que nous
nous concitoyens ont besoin d'avoir
autre chose que ce que je dirais être
les parties prenantes habituelles et
j'ai été surpris dans mes activités
personnelles à VNF notamment je peux
citer que à minuit à Nogent-sur-Seine il
y a 300 personnes qui débattent d'un
projet et pourtant ils n'en sont pas les
acteurs pourquoi la CNDP fondamentale
sur tous ces projets parce que plus
d'une fois ce n'est pas les acteurs du
territoire qui directement vont subir
les conséquences
qui pardon ce sont les acteurs du
territoire qui ont subi directement les
conséquences et souvent des avantages
qui sont beaucoup plus globaux plus
nationaux et c'est cette interaction qui
est nécessaire après je pense que nous
sommes passés un deuxième phase monsieur
le rapporteur d'air qu'avant on
cherchait le consensus sur un projet
aujourd'hui le consensus est plus
difficile à obtenir donc on est plus
sur l'affichage
réel des controverses que font ces
projets et chaque citoyen je pense
naturellement le droit d'avoir sa
position sur le sujet ça m'envoie tout
de suite à ce que vous disiez madame la
sénatrice sur le l'électronique
l'électronique mais même aujourd'hui
pour être très clair le la réunion
publique on voit bien que la
participation on doit réinventer
d'autres modes de participation on doit
aider les gens à accéder la Commission
nationale de débat public a fait
beaucoup de de d'exercices de nature
être dans une gare pour parler avec les
gens moi j'ai fait un exercice sur le
Plan de Déplacement Urbain
d'Île-de-France c'est 400 000 personnes
qui ont répondu à une carte T2 donc il
faut qu'on réinvente ces systèmes
complémentaires à des systèmes j'allais
dire mécaniques et informatique qui ne
permettent pas l'accès
donc oui on développera autant que
possible des expérimentations pour
compléter ces ces consultations
électroniques qui sont parfois
difficiles à accéder aux gens
est-ce que les débats sont apaisés non
les débats ne sont jamais apaisés ce qui
est important et ce qui est fondamental
que cité souvent Chantal Jouanno c'est
pas que le débat soit apaisé c'est que
le citoyen qui a participé à un débat
voit le retour qu'en fait alors si je
prends techniquement le maître d'ouvrage
ou l'acteur de la politique qu'est-ce
qu'il en a pris et tout le travail on
appelle ça la reddition des comptes
c'est tout le travail de fond de la CMDP
dans les années à venir c'est de bien
pouvoir demander au maître d'ouvrage
c'est tradition on a progressé sur le
fait qu'il y a une maintenant une
concertation continue mais que dans
cette concertation continue le maître
d'ouvrage le constructeur un
gouvernement sur des politiques
nationales puissent montrer à quel point
il a toujours pris en compte ce qui est
ressorti du débat ou de la concertation
et ça ce point est le plus difficile
parce que on avait une tendance à avoir
un projet qui qui s'ouvrait qui avait
son débat public on fermait le dossier
on faisait préparer des dossiers
techniques on préparait des
autorisations des enquêtes publiques et
après on réalise le projet des fois le
temps est très long le l'environnement
même de ce projet a pu changer
sur le
sur la le déport très simplement moi
j'ai fait une première liste de projets
dont je suis certain je la soumettrai à
mes collègues de la commission elle fera
l'objet d'un avis public
c'est essentiellement des projets
routiers c'est 5 dernières années tout
de même il y a beaucoup moins de grands
projets en plus il y a des maîtres
d'ouvrage qui sont identifiés je prends
l'exemple du canal sunnord c'est plus
l'état c'est une
société régionale qui a pris la main on
a décentralisé ce projet et et c'est sur
ce sujet là sur lequel si Dieu y avoir
un débat je ressaisirais d'abord
évidemment la commission complète
interne la CNDP et évidemment la Haute
Autorité de la vie publique pour qu'elle
me donne des recommandations je crois
que mais pour vous situer le décompte
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui alors c'est
mon propre décompte pas encore
rediscuter et de l'ordre d'une dizaine
de projets
sur 80 dont les concertations sont
continues ou sont en cours donc je j'ai
pas de crainte de dire sur ce sujet que
je peux présenter les choses et
l'organisation interne de la CMDP a
prévu ce cas
le deuxième point c'est par rapport à
des pressions du gouvernement ou des je
n'ai pas été que dans des cabinets
ministériels j'ai passé 40 ans de
fonction publique avec à peu près tous
les gouvernements qui ont pu me demander
des choses
c'est plutôt parce que je suis dans une
fin de carrière que je suis arrivé à des
postes de trop nature
j'ai toujours porté une attention
particulière et je le répète à l'écoute
de tous et de toutes
quelles que soient leurs origines
politiques ou associatives donc j'ai
beaucoup travaillé avec des
organisations environnementales
parce qu'en plus j'ai la conviction que
au-delà de nos projets un certain nombre
de personnes n'ont pas beaucoup de
défense c'est la nature et et les
défenseurs sont parfois difficiles
notamment entre ce qu'on appelle
l'activité humaine et la nature
pour le
pour répondre à vos questions sur le
sénateurs niveau sur le
les réformes je vous dis très
sincèrement au jour d'aujourd'hui on m'a
présenté ces éléments hier les gens de
la scène d'épée m'ont présenté ce qu'ils
avaient reçu je vous ferai un avis écrit
en tant que CNP si vous me désignez je
suis gêné sur deux points dans cette
dans ce texte au jour d'aujourd'hui
le premier
et c'est un point technique que je vais
vous dire c'est a été émis un moment
l'idée que pour que la continuité se
fasse le garant de la CNDP devienne le
commissaire enquêteur or par principe
même mais par méthode la CNDP est
indépendante et ne donne pas d'avis de
là de venir le l'analyse de la de
l'enquête publique qui peut aller
jusqu'à 2000 pages ou 3000 pages pour
une giga Factory qui sur un délai de 3
ans
à 22000 pages pour Sene Nord sur le lot
j'ai une difficulté
qui est liée alors là sur la partie
enquête publique c'est-à-dire en fait on
met énormément de dossiers techniques à
disposition des gens et je suis pas sûr
que la synthèse qui puisse en être faite
s'il n'y a pas le l'avis de l'autorité
environnementale qui est lui a instruit
elle a instruit la totalité des choses
on a une vraie difficulté
pour le
pour l'énergie je reviens je franchement
je suis convaincu que les les dizaines
de débats qui ont déjà eu lieu sur
l'énergie à la CNDP qui ont fait l'objet
d'une fiche d'un document d'éclairage
que ces deux débats qui viennent de se
produire tout d'abord ils ont montré une
indépendance de la CNDP mais qui a
permis de faire après une première
demande d'un Premier ministre une
deuxième demande de garant de la de la
première ministre actuelle un exercice
plein et entier sur la concert sur le
mix énergétique dans les pur règne de la
CNDP même si une concertation menée par
le gouvernement j'imagine que quand la
loi c'est sera prête vous en verrez la
présentation
sur le citizenbaching et la droite la
participation moi j'ai une conviction
personnelle alors je suis un homme
d'État de projet assez long je
reviendrai j'ai ma phrase structure de
transport de se déroulait pas en
quelques jours et c'est pas un mois de
moins ou de plus de concertation qui
était le le point de fond par contre
j'ai toujours apprécié la possibilité
alors à l'époque peut-être il y a 15 ans
de chercher des consensus aujourd'hui de
bien voir les controverses pourquoi
parce que ces controversions ne les
purge pas si on ne les explique pas si
le maître d'ouvrage ne passe pas ce
temps
elles reviennent toujours ensuite
par contre j'ai vu il y a le croient
quatre projets de giga Factory dans les
hauts de France
sont les gigas Factory il y a une
saisine qui a dû aller en grand lieu fin
2020 et fin 2023 les batteries sont en
cours de production donc le temps
qu'il est toujours donné sur la le débat
public et est assez
peut être très bien géré en dans un
temps court
l'important est tous les maîtres
d'ouvrages y compris les gigafactory le
10 dans leur rapport c'est que ça a
servi à purger des sujets qui n'étaient
peut-être pas
vous avez d'autres domaines où on peut
imaginer qu'on va que sur un endroit
alors qu'en fait les effets de ce projet
sont beaucoup plus larges à titre
personnel je suis convaincu que sur des
projets complexes nous avons intérêt à
voir ce qu'on appelle un cadrage
préalable de l'autorité environnementale
assez rapide mais qui permettent de voir
la totalité des sujets pour ne pas les
voir arriver ensuite après des éléments
un peu long
voilà qu'on mes premières réponses
merci je vais donner la parole à Angèle
Préville
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
candidat donc sur la CNDP qui est qui se
préoccupe du la protection de
l'environnement qui consiste à informer
et à potentiellement permettre des
débats je voulais je souhaitais vous
interroger et avoir votre regard voir
votre avis sur un fait et là je vais
parler de fake qui est que la
biodiversité s'effondre en France nous
perdons nous avons des espèces menacées
de disparition
24% des reptiles 23% des amphibiens 32%
des oiseaux nicheurs qu'elle regard vous
portez sur ces sujets là qui sont les
sujets de fond en fait
et sur le fait que la connaissance ne
ruisselle pas vraiment dans notre pays
que nous avons besoin d'avoir des avis
éclairés et que la demande de
participation comme cela a été évoqué
par mes collègues et très forte comment
faire de la CNDP un instrument adapté
enjeux actuels ou très forte demande de
participation du public il s'agit pour
une institution déjà de qui date déjà de
25 ans d'amplifier et de s'adapter
vraiment à ce que sont les
problématiques actuelles donc voilà je
souhaitais avoir votre avis sur ce sujet
du déclin de la biodiversité parce qu'en
fait il s'agit de cela et vous avez
mentionné les deux tiers des projets
sont modifiés
est-ce que c'est un pisalet et il faut
modifier ou bien est-ce que ce sont des
choses vertueuses qui nous faut mettre
en place absolument voilà je vous
souhaitez avoir votre regard
merci la parole est à Bruno Belin merci
monsieur le Président je ouais salut et
remercier notre rapporteur aussi pour sa
présentation alors moi je vais reprendre
les mêmes expressions que de nos
collègues qui viennent d'intervenir à me
prévient les mêmes filleuls sur votre
regard personnel votre lecture
personnelle le regard que vous apportez
la scène des P adaptée aux enjeux
actuels mais alors sur un tout autre
sujet qui ne va pas les coller beaucoup
sur les industries vertes mais qui
aujourd'hui mobilise le Sénat sur la
question de la pénurie de médicaments
sauf que si on veut réindustrialiser en
France ce type de production on se rend
compte et ça évidemment à folle un peu
certains élus que on a affaire à des
sites qui sont classés ces vaisseaux au
niveau
alors comment peut-on là encore pallier
tous les enjeux parce que ce qui a été
présenté par l'imprévu de Madame viole
évidemment on rejoint on partage ça nous
préoccupe autant mais on a aussi besoin
d'avoir cette souveraineté et donc on se
positionne aujourd'hui sur des projets
qui sont ces vaisseaux au niveau je dois
avoir votre regard votre lecture
personnelle merci monsieur le président
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Jean-Michel Houlgate merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur papinutti donc je
voudrais un peu revenir sur cette
injonction contradictoire d'une part le
temps long du déroulement des projets et
de la nécessité du temps de la
concertation et puis celui de l'urgence
que ce soit dans le domaine de
d'apporter des réponses en matière de
réindustrialisation ou en matière de
défi par rapport au changement
climatiques je voudrais également
revenir sur la commission spéciale du
débat public sur penlis il se trouve que
j'ai
assisté donc à la restitution la semaine
dernière par Michel Badré notamment et
ce débat il faut reconnaître a été très
fructueux 5000 contributions 5000
participants une multitude de réunions
publiques mais il faut reconnaître que
ce débat malheureusement et Michel
baderell a dit il s'est terminé en queue
de poisson il s'est terminé en queue de
poisson pourquoi parce que il a été
torpillé par à la fois des décisions
gouvernementales et aussi par des
décisions parlementaires dont on porte
il faut reconnaître la responsabilité
décision gouvernementale de nommer
quasiment deux jours après l'ouverture
des débats d'un délégué une idée de la
création d'une délégation par décret
interministériel au nouveau nucléaire
avec un nouveau délégué qui qui est Joël
bar l'ancien DGA la décision par le
Parlement de déplafonné entre guillemets
les les
la loi sur comment dirais-je la
production d'électricité nucléaire
notamment avec les 62 gigawatts
installés et ainsi de suite et puis
aussi le Conseil national le Conseil de
politique nucléaire qui a été je dirais
le coût d'arrêt de la concertation alors
justement quelle aura été si vous aviez
été dans la position d'être déjà
président de la CNDP quel aura été votre
attitude par rapport à je dirais ces
injonctions gouvernementales d'une
certaine façon d'aller très vite et
d'accélérer le développement du
nucléaire notamment
merci la parole est à tech oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
candidat
je pense qu'on est sur un débat assez
essentiel aujourd'hui qui à travers
votre candidature et évidemment aussi
l'avenir de la scène des sociétés qui se
tend
on voit l'effondrement de la démocratie
sociale ça c'est l'actualité des
derniers mois on voit ça a été dit par
certains de mes collègues de loin en loi
des tricotages d'une partie du processus
notamment sur le droit environnemental
sur quoi avait incité Chantal Jouanneau
je vais pas être plus long dans les
numérations et on voit dans l'autre sens
la montée des tensions et la montée des
violences et effectivement pour
réapaiser la société il faut absolument
des arbitres du débat je reprends vos
termes y compris pour purger un certain
nombre de questions et ramener
l'ensemble des citoyens vers le débat
public et ne pas considérer que ça se
joue sur d'autres terrains
à partir de là
vous vous avez insisté sur le fait que
la CNDP par définition ne prenez pas
position
mais on a une vraie difficulté dans le
débat public qui est qu'on a une
évolution du débat public vers des
affrontements d'affirmation dont une
part importante et fausse généralement
des deux côtés et effectivement si
s'agisse juste de faire deux colonnes
des arguments pour des arguments contre
ce qui a été l'échec absolu de la CNDP
sur le projet d'aéroport de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et elle a eu
beaucoup de mal à s'en remettre et ce
qui a en fait tué le référendum derrière
dans l'incapacité de la CNDP d'organiser
le débat
est-ce que
en tant que grand commis de l'État
quel sera votre attitude face aux
arguments alors les Antilles les
opposants peuvent aussi avoir des
arguments fantaisistes je suis pas
caricatural mais mon expérience sans
être sinon que la vôtre montre que
l'État peut ici là pipoter des données
on a eu des études courbes bénéfices par
exemple totalement excentriques ne pas
donner toutes les informations et que ça
nourrit énormément la colère donc si la
CNDP se contente effectivement d'acter
les arguments des uns des autres puisque
évidemment les neutres mais si elle ne
prend pas position sur des arguments
dont vous saurez vous avec vos langues
expériences notamment venant de l'État
qui ne sont pas juste voir fantaisistes
comment allez-vous intervenir sur cette
question précise est-ce que vous vous
donnez le droit de dire à l'état voilà
faut quand même pas pousser refait de la
copie et de le dire publiquement où
est-ce que vous allez rester dans une
neutralité qui est finalement on fait
deux listes d'arguments le débat a lieu
ne satisfait personne et se continue
ensuite avec les moyens qu'on voit
monter d'une société de plus en plus
crispée
merci chers collègues Didier Mandelli
monsieur le Président
si je devais résumer l'ensemble des
interventions que nous venons d'entendre
qui rejoignent ma question je dirais
simplement comment rendre demain
monsieur le candidat audible visible et
crédible la CNDP et je vais reprendre
quelques exemples qui ont été donnés à
la fois par Jean-Michel goulatte et on
entendait un instant
comment rendre audible et crédible la
CNDP
au moment où notre nos concitoyens
inspirent à une plus grande
participation au débat on parle beaucoup
de participation démocratie
participative etc etc et quand on
regarde la réalité
parvenir sur le débat et là faire un
dogme sur Notre-Dame-des-Landes avec le
résultat qu'on connaît comment dévoyé
comment demander à des gens de prendre
position et ensuite ne pas en tenir
compte la position également dans le
cadre du grand débat intuitif à trustter
préempté phagocyté
ces discussions qui n'ont débouché sur
pas grand chose si ce n'est la
distribution de quelques milliards
d'euros pour compenser ponctuellement et
puis je vais prendre un autre exemple
c'est la mise en oeuvre des conventions
citoyennes et donner la place par
l'exécutif au Césaire sur la mise en
oeuvre de ces débats ces discussions sur
des sujets sociétaux et avec notamment
environnementaux avec les résultats
qu'on connaît donc et d'exécutif ou
président bien précis d'ailleurs que le
Césaire devait être le lieu du débat
public en tout cas lui donner cette
dimension après avoir voulu le supprimer
donc la vraie question c'est
quel président demain pour la CNDP qui
puisse avoir l'autorité la dimension
politique aussi suffisante le poids
suffisant pour imposer la CNDP et lui
donner sa
vraie dimension
d'organisateurs de fédérateur et de mise
en oeuvre du départ public sur tous les
grands sujets qui intéressent nos
concitoyens alors je vais pas reprendre
les propos évidemment du rapporteur ni
de ce qu'on peut dire les uns les autres
moi je mets pas du tout en doute vos
compétences et aux qualités on a eu
l'occasion de travailler ensemble
notamment sur la lame avec Isabelle
borne je connais votre attachement
discussion inconcertation et à
l'ouverture
est-ce que la vraie question c'est
est-ce que vous êtes prêt aujourd'hui
assumer ce rôle vis-à-vis d'exécutif
pour que la CNDP prenne toute sa place
merci chers collègues monsieur papinetti
je vous propose de répondre
aux nombreuses questions et
interrogations de mes collègues
je veux dire sur la
biodiversité c'est à dire quelques mots
sur la biodiversité parce que j'y suis
particulièrement attaché depuis des
années on a deux sujets dont un qui est
abordé régulièrement par la CNDP je
dirais c'est le stock et le flux le flux
des nouvelles infrastructures ou de
nouveaux projets soit linéaire soit
ponctuel qui vient les choses et puis il
y a le stock quand je parle du stock
j'ai été des aides VNF on croit que NF
fait que du transport nous on fait aussi
beaucoup d'environnement puisqu'on gère
une partie importante des oiseaux
sur ce qui est du flux on commence à
savoir travailler mieux et je pense
qu'on qu'on a des règles des règlements
et qui permettent d'avancer les choses
sur le stock on a un sujet qui
d'ailleurs remonter par des associations
quand on voit les décomptes qui se les
de nombreux qui sont d'espèces où il
avait cité ou des mouvements d'insectes
des nombreux
et moi je vais peut-être plus loin je
trouve qu'on n'a pas le bon indicateurs
pour en parler facilement y compris au
public y compris au grand public y
compris sur les débats de grand public
je parle là de du stock dans toute la
France métropolitaine dans les outre-mer
dans la mer on aura le débat sur les
façades sera aussi un débat qui ne sera
pas que sur l'énergie je pense qu'il y
aura la manière dont on peut se
concevoir
l'océan demain et la place et on voit
déjà des des crispations sur sur des
sujets donc oui il y a une demande il
faut prolon inventer le le process
c'est pour ça que je citais dans mes
propositions c'est qu'on est une fiche
entre guillemets biodiversité et je
pense qu'il y aura des moments
politiques sur lequel le
la préparation d'une telle réflexion
serait importante alors je sais pas si
c'est la forme d'un débat d'une
concertation si c'est une saisine de
vous parlementaire mais voilà
sur sur l'injonction du temps long et du
temps court ce que je dis ce que je
continuerai de dire sur la
sur la scène des
c'est une expérience personnelle je le
répète c'est le fruit de 30 ans ou 40
ans de travail le temps long qu'on croit
être trop long en amont n'est jamais
trop long puisque après il vous l'avait
cité plusieurs fois
Notre-Dame-des-Landes on voit bien que
c'était un très très long et finalement
non mais pour il n'a pas de décrispé un
certain nombre de sujets
de fond
et donc ce temps le temps qui si on a un
mois de plus de concertation c'est quand
même mieux ou si on a
si on a pris le temps d'ouvrir
complètement le sujet ce qui est aussi
une conception un peu plus complexe
laquelle la CNDP tient beaucoup et
auquel moi j'avais tenu plus d'une fois
d'avoir des scénarios des scénarios
alternatifs pour le débat au moment pas
au moment où on est en train de faire
l'enquête publique parce que là c'est
trop tard je vous l'ai dit il y a 20000
documents et parce qu'il y a du CV
vaisseau parce qu'il y a ceci parce que
ceux-là il y a une réglementation qui a
deux entrées l'entrée française l'entrée
européenne et l'entrée environnementale
l'entrée risque industrielle enfin une
motorisation qui fait difficile de
déroger par en claquement de doigt mais
si en amont on a on a posé les questions
et on a entendu les réponses on a
quelque chose difficile par contre de
dire que la CNDP la CNDP elle peut du
style de dire qu'on va lui faire prendre
une position une posture
je pense que son rôle reste actuellement
dans les textes tels qui sont définis
dans la convention Darius aussi c'est
d'être certain qu'on a interrogé les
citoyens que ceux-ci ont pu et c'est ça
le deuxième point sur lequel je serai
c'est le changement de qui s'est mis en
place quand on a fait la concertation
continue
c'est-à-dire peut-être même après lors
de la construction enfin je sais pas il
faut aller mais de vérifier que les
choses vont jusqu'au bout de ce que les
citoyens ont pris ce jour-là on gagnera
on gagnera la crédibilité dans un
ensemble de projets etc si les citoyens
au bout de 10 ans quoi les choses par
contre le temps long est capable parfois
complexe parce que à l'inverse moi j'ai
vécu très personnellement un projet
en 2002 j'ai négocié les hauteurs un
certain nombre de protections phoniques
parce que le bruit est aussi un problème
environnemental réel elles ne sont pas
encore construites puisque le projet
n'est qu'à moitié construit etc donc
faut qu'on trouve cette alternative sur
le vous avez cité tout à l'heure les les
réglementations ces vaisseaux danger et
autres les instructions sont sont
données à tous les services et une des
recommandations que j'ai vu dans un des
rapports des multiples rapports que j'ai
lu mais là je me donne 2 à 3 mois de de
synthèse avec la scène les membres de la
CNDP c'est qu'il y a un chef de projet
du côté de l'État ce que nous avons fait
sur des canal comme celle Nord ce que
j'ai pu faire sur un contrat de
partenariat sur des barrages en
Champagne-Ardenne à l'époque puis
maintenant en grand est que en fait il y
a quelqu'un à l'état qui soit le
concentrateur et qui qui gère toutes ces
procédures parce qu'elles sont complexes
elles ont des parties techniques assez
fortes
et on y gagne probablement du temps et
que le maître d'ouvrage lui-même n'a pas
les compétences parce que dans notre
projet de gigafactory vous voyez bien
par exemple que c'est des nouvelles
entreprises dans le médicament ça sera
des entreprises qui existent déjà mais
est-ce qu'elles ont fait ça en France ou
en Europe probablement pas donc comment
on se remet dans le donc il faut qu'on
ait les deux du côté état je pense le
chef de projet qui qui n'est pas
simplement assez servi à la maîtrise
d'ouvrage c'est c'est le mais qui
simplifie le simplificateur c'est une
conviction personnelle chaque fois où
j'ai pu le mettre en place j'ai eu un
des éléments de réussite sur ce point
c'est interditecte vous situiez la
richesse des données alors moi je vais
je pense qu'on a on a un sujet
d'abord de communication mais je veux
dire c'est pas à vous que je veux dire
que j'entends pas au journal télévisé
qu'on parle des débats publics quelques
exceptions près de depuis quelques
années donc on a un problème de
connaissance et de communication et dans
les ETP supplémentaires qui ont été
donnés à la CNDP il y aura quelqu'un qui
travaillera sur les données les données
recueillies par la CNDP pour pouvoir les
mettre plus à l'accès du public c'est
pas pour autant qu'on prendra position
mais qu'on donne les informations et on
a vraiment ce sujet du FAC checking
celui là il est il est le plus difficile
mais je peux checking on peut dire des
fois avec le maître d'ouvrage est à
peut-être fait aussi des données
la CNDP le contre-pouvoir de faire des
expertises complémentaires des
excellentes supplémentaires et aucun des
débat public ne s'en est gêné quand ça
paraissait nécessaire c'est contre
expertise elles sont à l'évidence
nécessaire sur Saintonge de sujets
environnementaux dans un premier temps
mais aussi de crédibilité de ce qui est
dit et ça c'est
on va pas dire que c'est un
contre-pouvoir c'est juste le pouvoir de
la CNDP de mettre à place ces choses on
sera beaucoup ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile
dans le dans un débat live où je pense
ou la l'a l'aberration donnée c'est la
position d'une personne et on la CNP
n'est pas là pour interdire aux uns aux
autres de non-exposition
le tout dernier point
qui a été soulevé
je suis
j'ai pas d'état d'âme enfin voilà on va
parler front parce que je suis là pour
parler franc et dévoilément ma
candidature j'ai pas d'être un homme
avait une position forte pour la CNDP
j'y crois j'y crois et je l'ai vécu
par contre ça ne sera pas tout seul et
je veux dire si je suis là et si je vous
ai proposé des
présentations de membres de la CNDP ou
demain de présentation pour les débats
qu'on va faire
c'est à nous de vous si je suis si vous
me désignez à la CNP c'est à nous de
faire ensemble ce pas là parce que le
l'éloignement la CNDP c'est pas une
instance totalement autonome décroché
tous elle est là pour les citoyens pour
les défendre et pour qu'ils permettent
de donner leur avis mais elle est aussi
là pour que les parlementaires s'en
emparent je vous dis il y a des j'ai pas
vu beaucoup de saisines faites par les
parlementaires elle est là aussi pour
répondre à vos questions comme je le
fais aujourd'hui mais j'en suis pas
membre donc je le ferai probablement
plus facilement dans trois mois quand
j'aurai essayé de d'échanger avec mes
vice-présidents et avec la commission
sur le programme qui peut on peut avoir
mais
il faut il faut assumer un rôle
d'indépendance il faut assumer une place
à la CNDP mais il faut aussi qu'elle l'a
que toutes les décisions qu'on prend ou
que les actes qu'on en fait on prennent
le temps de vous en reparler on prenne
le temps d'avoir des acteurs de
territoires qui sont des délégués
territoriaux de la CNDP pour que pour
qu'ils en parlent localement
et je dirais ce qui me surprend le plus
c'est que pour avoir vu beaucoup de
sujets je m'aperçois que dans les
collectivités territoriales notamment
des fois petites ou grandes pour prendre
l'exemple que le scène est porte à
barreaux connaît bien sur les aides Lyon
ou Grenoble ont demandé une assistance
méthodologique à
la
CNDP et les résultats vont ont été
efficaces c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu une
concertation avec des méthodes par
exemple comme on peut pas faire un
certain nombre de choses tester tout le
monde mais il y a eu des ménages
échantillons je crois à Lyon pour pour
essayer sur la mobilité je le dis parce
que je suis surpris c'est qu'au niveau
territorial et local les demandes d'avis
et d'expertise sont beaucoup plus fortes
que elles le sont nationales peut-être
parce qu'on a aussi moins de grands
projets
le COI ayant rendu son rapport certains
ont mis en participé j'imagine que
peut-être qu'on verra renaître des
projets voilà ce que je voulais répondre
merci
Monsieur papinutti donc si il y a plus
de questions de la part de de mes
collègues
je vais vous libérer
et puis donc nous allons
procéder au vote
merci à vous tous et tous